hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash popcorn box candy wrappers hmm
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me and thank you
for considering your fellow patrons
welcome to the Tim Dylan show everybody
we are here in Dallas Texas and we've
got Brendan Schaub coming up we have a
lot of fun talking to him he was in town
doing the Addison improv Joe Rogan was
in town doing the American Airlines
Center in downtown Dallas and Tony
himself was in town opening for Joe so
we had a lot of West Coast people
invading the dallas-fort Worth area the
Metroplex as they call it what I you
know shall be standing in a really nice
hotel right down by where Kennedy JFK
committed suicide in the middle of the
road so I saw that they have an X nice
and fun and real creepy on the street
where he got whacked and you you you you
you know and then last night I was in
the early show the early shows real
drunk I mean they were good they were
decent they were fun but they were real
drunk and you get the feeling I'm like
these [ __ ] would kill Kennedy
all over again they'd kill him again you
just you just get the vibe that these
people would would [ __ ] shoot that guy
in the head again that nothing has
really changed nada
nothing's really changed they would just
go in these [ __ ] would go in and get
rid of that guy ASAP nope no questions
asked you get that feeling here when you
walk around Texas you get the feeling
like if there was ever a place for a COO
in this country it's gonna be here it's
gonna be here and it was like if there's
ever a place to get rid of the guy that
says maybe we should stop like you know
lifting [ __ ] uranium from the Amazon
and maybe the CIA shouldn't be in a fact
government like if there was ever a
place to shoot that guy in the head in
front of his wife it was it's here and
you get that by the audience's you're
like oh yeah you guys are you guys are
down you guys are with it there will be
video for Schaub I know many of you
complain about the video here's what we
don't give a [ __ ] about YouTube anymore
and we're doing YouTube as a way to make
the experience better for everybody we
like being on camera we like the video
but the reality is YouTube is over it's
done they're taking everybody's money
they're not allowing people to monetize
their channels guys ik david dobrik who
have hundreds of millions of views are
talking about that their ad revenue has
been [ __ ] cut so I have nothing
compared to these people so a lot of the
big youtubers guys like Logan Paul or
whatever they've started podcasts h3h3
because they're smart and they know that
the ad revenue is gonna be made up for
in podcasting YouTube is [ __ ] done
with small creators they're done they
don't want independent creators they
want that's why when you go to youtube
and you you know YouTube Jeffrey Apps in
the first five videos or MSNBC CNN and
they all have 70 or 80 thousand views no
one gives a [ __ ] but all of those
corporate companies are now dominating
YouTube even though you know Luke
radowski who's stuck on Epstein's island
video has close to a million views which
should have more by the way but they're
not promoting that in the same way that
they're promoting the corporate media
videos and this is just the end of the
road we knew it was gonna happen they
can deactivate your channel now if what
you do isn't commercially viable
in their new contract with ban uploads
videos they go is just suitable for
children and if you say yes and it's not
they can sue you obviously nothing we do
is suitable for children everything is
adult comedic you know satirical videos
and podcasts none of which are you know
appropriate for children but this is
what YouTube is not doing they are
getting out of the business of small
creators would essentially built them
and they're getting into the business I
mean YouTube will be Netflix you guys
can't go on Netflix can't go on Netflix
and start a channel and that's gonna be
what YouTube eventually is that's just
what it is
you know there was probably some
smoke-filled room
at the Bilderberg conference with the
Davos conference where a bunch of guys
were like we've had just about enough of
this technology has allowed people to go
out there and truly ruffle the feathers
of billionaires that haven't had those
feathers ruffled for decades and I think
in the beginning they tolerated it and
it even helped them because technology
was just this way that you could
complain about things but not take any
action so it was a simulation
essentially this world that you could
kind of just you know participate in but
those people it was like it was like
great
let him tweet let him let him you know
talk to each other on Facebook let him
let him vent all their grievances online
we're never gonna have to do with it
well then what happened online started
to get a little too real you know people
like Donald Trump got elected brexit you
know happened all of these things that a
lot of people and I'm not saying these
are good things or bad things and I I'm
not saying that the people are all gonna
make the right choices all the time
anyway but empowering people is not on
the agenda of the elites this is just
not part of the thing they want people
to feel empowered and not be empowered
they want you to feel good but they
don't want you to have the power to
really do anything
certainly not upset the world order that
they've really created so some where
there was a smoke-filled room in Davos
and they were going you know this has
been cute this has been fun we've
allowed them to have a little bit of fun
but now it's time to rein it in now it's
time to shut it down now it's time to to
basically hand the internet over to the
corporations that we handed television
over to and these [ __ ] aren't stupid
they know TV's eventually done so what
do you think all these massive media
corporations are not going to come in
and suck the money out of out of the
internet now that's what they're gonna
do the internet for a long time was just
freewheeling Wild West you could do what
you wanted you could start a channel you
could go viral you could get views you
could build an audience you could
monetize it gabay that is over they're
done with that and I truly believe we're
may be the last generation of people to
find ways I'm not saying that no one
will ever
find ways to monetize content again they
will it's the reality of what it is it's
human nature this is where a lot of
people are now making a living but you
know right now it's gonna be tough so
when all you [ __ ] complain no video
oh shut up you're lucky you get anything
this channel could go goodbye really
soon and by the way channels with
500,000 subscribers 1 million
subscribers 10 million they can be wiped
off YouTube if they're not quote-unquote
commercially viable and if they're not
making YouTube enough money and I think
it really goes back to the idea that the
people in power are not really thrilled
with the idea that you can create a
channel on YouTube that gets more views
than the nightly news that means that
they are losing the power and the
they're losing control of what you are
watching and what you are listening to
that is not in their plan they do not
like that and I guarantee there was some
meeting somewhere on one of these big
conferences where they basically said
you know what this has been a fun little
experiment we've enjoyed this we've
collected a lot of data we've learned a
lot of things but now it's time for the
adults to re-enter the room and carve up
this space this is just what it is is
what's happening right now the only
freedom left is podcasting which as
which just like radio has always been an
auditory format where you basically put
your words out there for people to
listen to that is probably all that's
gonna be left pot because once you
subscribe to my podcast for now by the
way until they find a way to [ __ ]
change this because Apple Apple already
has technology that is that is
transcribing all of the podcasts that
are happening and they're going back
there back logging and transcribing
podcasts it already happened why are
they doing that I don't know but that's
not a great sign I don't necessarily
love that and I don't know if they're
gonna say well you said these three
words in this combination and that means
you're out you're getting a strike three
strikes and you're gone I don't know but
I will tell you this as of right now
because all you have
to do is hit subscribe on a podcast feed
this is the only thing that they can
really take and by the way this is hard
to even complain about because if you
complain about this stuff people think
you're a Nazi because those are those
are the people that are getting thrown
the [ __ ] off so if you could play if you
like I don't do platformer people like
well what are you talking about what are
you talking about on there it's a hard
thing to complain about it's actually
one of those things where if you
publicly vent or complain to somebody
that you're getting D platforms of off
social media they're like what are you
doing talking about the shapes of skulls
what are you using your youtube chef for
it's like not dressing up like just
laying Maxwell and an in and out I'm
dressing up like Megan McCain but it's
still you know you're still you feel
weird talking about it because people
think you're some lunatic is trying to
start a race war when in fact you're
just [ __ ] making people laugh but the
problem is there's they don't want to
differentiate people that are actually
you know try and I'm sure there are
people out there a hundred percent that
are using YouTube to recruit people into
violent groups and whatever and I just
it we know that that's happening but
what they're gonna do is just get rid of
everybody that's even the least bit
controversial that's just what's gonna
happen and it's hard to complain about I
mean I can complain on my show about it
but and I can talk to people that are
aware of what's going on about it but
the general public doesn't care this is
my point the general public doesn't give
a [ __ ] they don't make really money off
youtube and if you start complaining
that you're the platform they think
you're crazy and you're doing something
wrong it's just the way it is
they don't care people love Authority
this is what people are into people like
well I'm sure you did something like
they don't necessarily they're not
siding with you and I get it because
every now and then there are people that
shouldn't be on these things doing crazy
stuff you know but that's the thing
that's the future the future is going to
be you click subscribe on the podcast
you're subscribed to the podcast that is
great until that changes and until they
can start [ __ ] with that algorithm
and god only knows and I hope they don't
but that's going to be
the last thing that's left pretty much
for everybody
YouTube channels are gonna are gonna
appear and disappear at the discretion
of YouTube I don't put a lot of videos
on Instagram anymore people ask me I
just made a fun Disney video you know
about some psychopath and by the way
enough with the Disney Plus [ __ ] off
enough grow up how many times you need
to watch [ __ ] Captain America over and
over again grow the [ __ ] up I understand
that it's probably a good service
whenever especially if you have kids or
whatnot and you want to introduce them
to that you know movies that they may
not have seen it's all in your living
room but if you're an adult without any
children and you're really excited about
Disney Plus you should be in jail okay
enough my friend Jared Logan is a very
funny comedian said once about Disney
because it's the first culture you're
exposed to it's not supposed to be the
[ __ ] last it's not supposed to be the
last culture you're exposed to it's the
first you're supposed to use that as a
jumping off point to get to other things
to get to other books and films it's not
just supposed to be the Lion King
forever and Disney cruises people go see
the Lion King on Broadway it's like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you figure it out
but this is what's gonna happen it's all
consolidation all of these major media
companies are merging the the era of the
independent crater I'm being a little
dramatic now but I think you might be
you might look back and go the era of
the independent creator is over where
you could just a really a massive
following and monetize what you're doing
it doesn't seem to be you know it
doesn't seem to be a model that is going
to last for right now so all you you
know and you guys can't really do
anything about it and I can't do much
about it you know the podcast seems to
be the last vestige of being able to say
what you want although they don't sure
they can take you of Apple podcast if
they want they don't seem to be doing
that I have a lot of friends a lot of
wild podcasts and you know they don't
seem to be doing that as of now it's all
for now it's all a limited time
only you know me and Luz Gomez how to
talk we're like maybe the final thing is
going to actually be the live show maybe
the reality is just gonna be if you want
to hear things you're gonna have to go
out live you can have to leave your
house buy a ticket sit in a comedy club
or a theater and hear what people say
live it may literally go back to that it
might just be a big circle that takes
you back to live performance because
there's just too many hands in the
cookie jar if it's not live
there's too many [ __ ] people and
corporate power structures that have to
get involved between what what what
people are creating and what you're
consuming there's just a lot so YouTube
is is pretty much over unless something
changes drastically and by the way they
prevent people you know nobody gets a
notification when I do a YouTube video
they don't notify we've got maybe 18 or
20 thousand people that are subscribed
to the channel we should have a lot more
but my videos are not appearing in sea
chat even though people love them and
they're funny they have a huge amount of
engagement YouTube doesn't even want
that anymore so they're not appearing in
a suggested videos and nobody's being a
lot of people are not being notified
when I post in your video so the tools
that YouTube has to limit my reach I
mean they're using they're certainly not
helping me build a fan base on YouTube
they're just not doing it they have no
interest in facilitating is this so Gary
Vee good question is it Gary Vaynerchuk
is how do I pissed off that I pissed off
Gary Vee now he's going around all the
tech companies I don't know I think it's
bigger than that I think they just don't
have an interest in independent creators
that's [ __ ] the way it is I'm very
late to the game I got into mortgages a
year before it collapsed I got
understand of comedy late to the game
this is just what I do as soon as I get
involved in something it's over they'll
probably get rid of podcasts in a year
as soon as I get good at something it's
done I'm just that guy I show up late to
the party all the good shits already
happened and I'm just air cleaning up
the kitchen and watching some girl vomit
that's what it is
so I show up late to the party so those
of you that are that are like what the
[ __ ] going on I know a lot of you
don't give a [ __ ] like I said it doesn't
affect you in your daily life you're not
making a living live-streaming
that's fine but listen go subscribe to
the YouTube channel for as long as it's
around stay subscribe to the podcast I'm
hoping to God that the podcast is just
the thing that indoors I'm hoping it
indoors because radio in some form or
another has endured
I think podcasting will endure as far as
the video content where that's gonna go
that's a great question I know that some
people are just hosting it on their own
websites you know the future of that I
don't know or YouTube might just be a
place you could Park your content but
very few people are gonna see it
relative to the amount of people that
would have seen it and you're not gonna
make any [ __ ] money that being said
we have a great interview coming up
Brendan Schaub I spend about an hour
with Brendan he's a really funny guy you
know people think I hate him for
absolutely no reason because I've made a
joke which mean him talk about with
Louis where I call him the greatest
comedian in the world which he's not
that's why it's funny but I could have
said that pretty much about anybody
because nobody's the greatest comedian
in the world comedy stupid it's a dumb
thing and all of you that are precious
about it all of you out there that are
like comedy snobs you're even dumber
than the people that are doing it
because it doesn't matter it's really
dumb I work my ass off on jokes to have
a unique perspective and the funniest
thing I say is that you know somebody
with a you know t-mobile phone has AIDS
or whatever and the audience goes crazy
at that it doesn't matter it's
irrelevant and you know I love it other
comedians love it it's what we've
dedicated our lives to but God does it
[ __ ] not matter at all so anybody out
there and it's like you think somebody
deserves to be successful somebody
doesn't deserve to be successful I get
it I understand you have strong opinions
but also understand that they don't
[ __ ] matter doesn't really matter
what you think you don't care we're
living in the United States of America
we're at the end of the Empire it's all
over all the trends are converging we're
gonna be rationing water soon so a matte
think these are gonna be the good times
when you guys were discussing which
clowns deserve their money in which
clowns did it which clown should have
had more I get it I get it out there but
this is gonna be the good times in 30
years when you walk outside and the Sun
fries you and your you know your kids
are [ __ ] you know
walking to school and you know 109
degree weather and everybody's got to
have some [ __ ] weird Sun cloak on and
it's like Mad Max you're gonna look at
this time ago you know that was a really
fun time that we had but I talked to
Brennan for about an hour we go into
everything from a lot of the online hate
that he gets we talk about how he
started in comedy we talked about the
fact that I'm a better swimmer than him
and Rogan and all of those guys even
though they think you're athletes
I'm I was a great swimmer we discussed
that we talked about politics a little
bit we get his feeling on on kids
playing football transgender athletes
who go through a real a real lightning
round of hot-button issues and I had a
lot of great time on that podcast a
fighter in the kid I'll see those guys
again soon hopefully and hopefully I'll
be on your mom's house we don't know
it's the ban is still in effect
apparently I missed that doctor true
episode and I didn't show up for it then
I was gonna be rebooked but that was a
while ago
so still no call from your mom's house
it is pretty
maybe tweet at them and say you guys
should have Tim Dylan on I don't know
don't annoy them be respectful but I
don't know I don't know we're still
we're still going we're still going
strong here with no reach out from the
your mom's house network they may have
no interest in me and that's okay that's
fine I'm not complaining it just is what
it is because people message me and they
look wherever you got on your mom so
it's like we had an incident I miss
doctor true I lied about it
there's a photo of me on the beach on
Instagram they all thought it was funny
supposedly hahaha that's what I was told
we don't know I scheduled to do doctor
true again I said listen guys I'm flying
in that day I don't want to miss the
[ __ ] thing again so can we reschedule
for another time it was like okay
haven't heard from them since you know
so you know whatever God loved them god
bless them maybe I'll do that in the
future but people that are email you
know that are [ __ ] messaging me
that's where we're at
we're here with radio silence from ymh
radio silence from your mom's house
network radio silence from dr. drew
maybe maybe they're mad at me that I
said that drew would tell people how
was good for them if there was enough
money in it which we know is true and
that's very funny because it's accurate
if if there was a heroin Lobby that took
that gave dr. drew money to go out and
tell you that you should the best thing
for your kids to do is shoot him up with
dope before he took him to school he
would absolutely sit there and do it
that's just a reality okay I don't even
necessarily blame him for that
it is what the [ __ ] it is Brendan Schaub
coming up okay we're good it's the Tim
Dillon show everybody live from Dealey
Plaza Texas with historian Brendan
Schaub you've done a lot of work a lot
of work with the county especially here
in Dallas a lot of work a lot of work
it's it's you're down you're doing the
Addison improv yes sir
I'm down you're doing hyenas in Fort
Worth Rogen's doing the American
Airlines Center look at us you know it's
just a lot of West Coast people the in
Dallas it's perfect that trifecta yeah
in Texas yeah it's good are you so
you're staying in a hotel that's like
literally walking distance from where
Kennedy was whacked I did it on purpose
yeah did you this is my fourth time
coming to Addison I take the tour every
year and every year you do the JFK tour
every year we do the government JFK tour
government I want that well-documented
government tour where they spiel the
[ __ ] to us but I know I know all the
stuff at you know that it's called out
so it didn't happen then it happened
everyone calm down that gonna happen
that did not happen so so you you go in
knowing I know Michael [ __ ] wrong
that was over here at there's actually
five shots they say - there's 5 3 Mets
one in the throat one hit in the back
who's on this tour just local tourists
interested who don't know [ __ ] so I fill
them in what's this is what's weird
yeah is so my brother Derek my feature
and then asan my opener MC when we walk
around I'm like explain like stuff I
know but there there's the homeless
community around there all black guys
for a reason yeah
up and like oh you don't know [ __ ] you
know and they dislike their gig here in
Dallas
oh so they're giving another tour it's a
side tour like what really happened Wow
like a meth homeless guy yeah it's
actually pretty interesting
respect I bet there I bet it's more
educational than the government shill
tour correct yeah yeah you know how in
Venice or like third street the bums are
like out there like maybe chuckling
maybe it's the one-man band yeah maybe
they're eating glass yeah these that's
their kind of third street interesting
Venice is an interesting thing to me
because I love Muscle Beach yeah because
it's a bunch of gay guys who've cured
themselves of AIDS by lifting weights
you're right I mean it's just dudes that
should have died 93 look at Arnold yeah
and they just somehow have pumped
themselves free of AIDS
it's impressive just I mean it's wild
another reason to work out yeah do you
have you ever gone down there I grew up
in Venice you grew up in Venice yeah in
the summers my dad would my uncle lived
there so we would me and my brother go
out there every summer so we'd work out
Gold's jazz my shoe or an athlete from
the beginning uh yes and no I mean yeah
I'm I grew up playing sports but in in
Venice it was like we'd go then the
summers me my brother just hanging on
the boardwalk wait my dad would give us
like our allowance for the week and we'd
buy fake Rolexes and we collect them
then he'd go back home he'd sell them to
the kids for way more expensive price so
you were a business guy as a hustle you
were smart from the beginning by the
fake Rolexes on the Venice Boardwalk
yeah sell them to your friends how old
eight nine eight or nine year olds
buying fake Rolexes yeah
where was this going out where where is
Laura you've been the Aurora Colorado
yeah where they had the shooting all the
shooting yeah and Dan Soder is from
there yeah me and Dan from the same
hometown and you guys played football
against each other rival high schools
rival high schools you guys are better
of course okay clearly interesting did
you know him at all or not really no not
really I didn't know him till I started
in the comedy scene then I was like what
kid comics are to Denver and there's TJ
Miller from Denver and then obviously
Dan soda are the big ones yeah Roseanne
he's Roseanne from there Sinbad okay
interesting
but it that's a bad ad it's a great
Denver Comedy Works a lot of people say
is the best club in the country been
there I have yeah
we opened for soda amazing Denver for
whatever reason I don't know if it's the
altitude or if the lack of oxygen or
it's just the audience's are great they
think everything's funny they think
everything's funny you feel like
Chappelle when you're out on the stage
it's almost too good it's hot it's
almost like the I sense we've done ice
house yeah where it's like I'm not this
funny right and you don't laugh then you
go somewhere in your real Club and eat
right that makes sense yeah
what show as he as simply used an
athlete because I was a swimmer when I
was younger and I will still beat you
how been race how competitive I was a
third fastest butterfly on Long Island
I'll destroy you how old how old a row
go on how old nine nine Brendan okay
eight or nine those are the the the
contributions of children to sports
don't matter really no yes
really what do you mean no one gives a
[ __ ] about you a lot of people give a
[ __ ] it moves the economy by the way
food nobody gives a [ __ ] and why's
everyone getting mad when they're
injected maybe boys become girls and
girls become boy it's a big deal it is a
big deal here's that you were the
butterfly third-fastest butter flour on
on Long Island I was it was it was
better it was better than me he had a
French name you know that guy that you
can't catch I was always just better up
here looking like that my mother knows
his name and he always destroyed me you
know really killed me about this kid he
never even saw me as competition he
always just kind of like looked at me it
was like and he was never friendly and
whatever but I was I was third I think I
got to second once but I never beat him
I wonder what the kid is doing now I
don't know but it was the Long Beach
tiger shark swim team hell at the time
swim teams in the country
my mom was a coach I was I was like hope
people see people like me and you
they're like oh what do they have in
common
athletics number one knew it because I
was doing athletic things as a kid I was
a tap dancer have you ever tap dance
no tough tap dances is is a skill agree
it's athletic it's super athletic it's a
ball the Riverdance that's crazy
what's up that's insane I know I can't
do that can you run as a kid though you
got hood actor
childhood our swimmer swimmer
tap-dancing well yeah because they would
think that like as a kid actor they were
like you got to learn how to tap-dance
just try to demean it it's kind of a
killer way about black people - they're
like you should just tap dance just
dance
you might just be put in something you
just got to learn how to dance or play
basketball you figure it out something's
gonna happen what I remember and I and I
say that because I remembered the best
feeling of my life which I haven't been
able to get back to you but it's only
been 30 years the best feeling of my
life not quite 30 was being thrown in a
pool Saturday morning that was freezing
swimming for two hours
I think getting out of the pool and and
then might see this is my parents room
either I would go have like McDonald's
breakfast yeah because it was like I
know I know but that was we grew up like
that Blundell Phelps eats McDonald he's
garbage yeah great swimmer Alta that was
the best feeling that I ever had was
working out and being healthy now
obviously I was nine
like achieving something though what it
was though it was achieving something it
was discipline it was a level it if it
was I knew no matter what happened my
parents were gonna scoop me out of bed
and throw me in a pool like a week yeah
four times a week but you have that now
but not as far as athleticism or
swimming if that now with stand-up and
podcasting yeah I always said you do it
a lot I mean I do it well I mean let a
lot I do as many as you can in LA it's
not as much as New York but I do a lot
that I podcast a lot and I make content
it's a lot of stuff going on so you know
your energies into that which I know
there's the discipline for that it's you
mean you're be harder than most
athletics is athletics whether it's
football MMA swimming like it there's a
blueprint on what you need to do for
this there's not no and also no one's
calling me hey Tim make sure you do your
sets tonight
so nobody you're disciplined now is in a
completely different Lane in ways that
made a lot of sense once you said it's
kind of like a chess game we're kind of
like you have to look at all the pieces
and decide like what's gonna be mmm you
know you have to decide what you're
gonna do you have to make a decision I
think maybe with athletics like you said
you're just running an algorithm yeah
it's an algorithm that guys who were way
more successful before you can follow
that
stand-up there's no there's no algorithm
there's nothing this game we plays in
broad strokes of what you should do but
there's blood boil okay get up you know
but it's like how much are you writing
how much you writing but how are you
buying a good jug make it a great joke
how do you respond after you it you know
it doesn't go well your road shows you
know it's like a lot more yourself now
the whole marketing that it's social
media aspect the podcast if you stand up
a lot of your friends are also people
that are athletic really only Joe I mean
I was gonna say Tony's not a flea I mean
like like are you friends with a lot of
comics there's someone I've let not
really I mean last night Alan's
athletics what challenges calendar but
like we don't do anything I'm trying the
only people with athletic backgrounds
would be broken that's Taekwondo
shaolin's athletic and you get into
comedy do you look around at these
people and you like these people are
animals like look around at comics and
sometimes how crazy they are the lack of
discipline so cuz all my friends have
discipline is [ __ ] that's a bad side
right
like in Brogan says all-time and I don't
take offense to it but it doesn't make
sense when people go oh he's bringing in
athletes work ethic / - yeah - comedy
it's like no it's just a work ethic it's
usually worse Scott has an insane work
yeah they work he works for hoping
that's insane worth it bird you like
right we work all my all my like
Christ's shirt like all my guys my frog
work worked their ass off so it's like I
view it different as like animals know
like these guys they're workhorses man
yeah what do you think when you look at
like what when you look at great
fighters hmm because you were in the UFC
for how long such as six years are you
you're still friendly with people on
that yeah I mean though my only really
association with it is I do the show on
Showtime called the food truck Diaries
right so we book the fighters but my
show on there now it's just really let
you know I talk about fighting and
fighting culture but it's more a
lifestyle show I don't have guests on
there anymore I say Brian food truck but
outside that that one fight show that I
do I follow the sport but did you watch
Logan Paul Cassie
I did look at somebody yeah yeah he's a
good dude I did his pocket it's like a
good I think people it's like one of
those other things where our people for
whatever reason don't like him but but
why but why but why because it's
insanely successful yeah I know but he
doesn't spend I get it that's a bit of a
character form yeah it's like the same
way like people hate Justin Bieber
but why yeah well yeah who gives a [ __ ]
right well there's a lot of animosity
you have it two people don't like you do
you think that's because you got people
feel like you're successful comedy and
because you come from this other
successful thing they don't feel like
you paid the right kind of dues do you
think it's that or do you think people
are just like I mean that it depends
like if you're yeah I don't know I I
think in but anyone cuz you're one of
the nicest people that I've ever met
most like a lot of comedians are not as
[ __ ] are s I mean really I mean so
the reality is and then I'll see like
some of the P like some of the hate you
get and I'm like I don't get it I guess
is because people either jealous or
people just have a this is weird with
comedy where like people are like this
person deserves success and this one
doesn't but then a remark asset if the
market tells you right there's a market
that it tells you right you know that
lets you know what your value is right
so the market decides what your value
it's not these group of haters on there
guys those people don't matter right so
when it comes to me and hate it's like I
don't see any of it I look I don't read
any comments I'm nothing right so I
don't see it but if people who I look up
to with his comics other successful
comics aren't upset as what what what
I'm doing nobody is no one no no
business is no it's when people are
dissatisfied with their own careers in
their own lives who are upset that
because maybe they think I'm taking
spots from them or yeah I'm selling out
Addison and they're not so they sign me
they got a dislike somebody they have to
somebody happy the other thing is too is
it's it's just like it's just their own
insecurities and also it's weird for
them because you know they might
associate me as who knows that maybe
when I was playing football so there's
oceans
ball player then when I went from
football to fighting they associated me
as a football player doing fighting but
then they only from fighting it's weird
for them to see me go from that to stand
up like well that that's not this idea
that we're whatever you go into you kind
of figure it out and there are people
that spend our entire lives not figuring
things out you're kind of figuring it
out you are figuring it out and maybe
there's just an animosity that comes
from that I get it I'm not mad right no
I don't see it so right I hear about it
and then it's like as long you know if I
show up tonight and there's no one there
then I'm people also don't understand
jokes like you don't understand kidding
around like there's somebody came on the
internet they're like oh don't hate
friended chops I teased Luis Gomez all
the time
I said I'm now a follower of you and not
him because you have an Aston Martin and
it's fights literally the funniest thing
in the world this little is and then I
go and I go cuz cuz Luis is like you
should have never tried Kido you're not
an athlete jobs that don't take jobs
advice you have to take my advice
because I used to be fat and shad was
never fat it shows likes fair that is he
was big right that I like Luis I have
any qualms cordless but you shouldn't I
say I fall showers if Ike sees the
greatest community that's ever lived and
don't like people online or like haha
see Tim Cole hates when I show up like
no it's a joke you idiot saying that any
one of us are the greatest comedian that
ever lived is ridiculous that includes
anybody right now doing arena like 100
percent 100 percent
it's outlandish but people are like it's
a war it's a fun and it's like these
people are it they're heavily invested
in that idea that's what they want what
they need that like yes they like drama
and like yeah yeah hit me up their day
was a ke have you heard this have you
heard that apparently you and I hate
each other everybody hates everybody and
Chris was over at my house right I'm
like I don't see any of it right yeah
it's what but people just kind of invent
these things but I think a lot of
resentment for some of these people are
right like I came in the game and I came
in in a different route where Brian
Collins my best friend we do a show
together right good comedian yeah then
me and him go on the road together
running live firing the kids so that
would those were my open mikes he's huge
which you're special my favorite part of
your special is the beginning of your
special
where you're in a mansion and you're
like the life of a comedian he's just
wild you know he's like this is the way
I was comics ladies got us on basketball
court he's like this is just us and
these also got like a beautiful kid in a
life I'm like this is not at all
anything that comedians are involved in
at all you know it's just life a
comedian you know here in my granite
kitchen and my huge house so people just
get heated to make it Angry but here's
the thing yeah a lot of people that they
get angry because maybe they're like oh
he the only reason he said this is my
favorite when they go blurry sells
tickets because he was in the UFC right
no no you have any UFC fighter trying to
sell tickets that Addyson improv doing
easy yeah it doesn't work like know
people might or they go or they go the
only reason he'd only reason he could
sell it is because the Joe Rogan okay
fair how many how many people has Joe
Rogan had on this show
yeah go side dead or not shot it doesn't
work that way right my fourth time here
so don't doubt that that kind of story
that they're painting right now with the
only reason cuz you say well that works
once you might go to a city and could
sell 500 days to be like dude he was
awful right no I sell out more take it
everywhere I go
yeah well those people like what you do
you like the podcast they you know the
podcast is huge numbers I think that
like I also do yeah tons of sets in LA
oh yeah yeah yeah what have you now you
have a son your son is three or four
years old three and a half if you have a
real life that's why you're not reading
YouTube comments give real life to
because your son goes to like a fancy
school fancy school are do you meet
celebrity parents yes is that weird
no they know who you are yeah like we
know who each other I like I won't say
who would I get in trouble if I say who
the school but as a guy who has played
Batman love and my girl goes wait till
it's game there's these like it's a
[ __ ] bomb I go yeah what'd you say
she goes why would they let this guy in
there I go that's the greatest living
actor yeah alive right
that's Batman [ __ ] yeah yes that's that
one that's Batman yeah yeah and then you
hit her but you know sunson why has to
have what she's Mexican do you when
you're raising a kid and he's gonna have
a lot of money it's gonna blow up
no no Pappas guys you're a lot of money
don't have a lot of money what he is
nobody what do you do when you're
raising a kid in a situation where he's
like how do you prevent that person from
becoming in la monster I know the type
of kids that we see on scooters on
Melrose that have YouTube channels that
combines some me maybe you two probably
proud always how do we how do you stop a
kid like that you gotta get them
motivated coming a soundcloud rapper I
know I know
little Uzi vert or some [ __ ] one of them
little whatever it is I don't want to
say any of them because that's their vol
died I got in trouble the other week cuz
I said one of them and it was a dead one
I'm sorry
it was Little Bo Peep or whatever I
respect them all I respect the game zan
follows me on Twitter little Zen father
at the little Zen Zen all right I I
think you got to make sure he's
interested in he has to have some sort
of passion right but you can't have just
like a weird kid is just floating and
doing drugs
yeah just driving dad's Aston Martin
around yeah yeah that can't have the can
so hopefully he gets motivated well I
don't care what support he wants player
must be an act or whatever but he has to
have some goal and that's gonna keep
them I hope on path he's got yeah or is
being a dad great or is it
anxiety-producing I'm both right because
you like scared of the world like you
just like oh my god man right you got to
make sure that we like the way I think
about it when you have babysitter's you
have things like that the dude how do
you I mean ice we had a new nanny a year
ago right I spied on her for four weeks
okay exactly that's exactly the bar go
home I was already at the park
interesting interesting so you're just
you're just spying on this be keeping an
eye on her and making sure that she's
Joe Gipp she's the chief cameras all the
house I'd watch him lay in bed at night
and then watch back what she did with a
crasher do you want to have more I have
another one coming too not this Tuesday
but next Tuesday wild
I know another boy one more
yeah are you gonna just keep goin I'm
down my girls Mex yeah and you know
she'll keep going don't she'll throw
them out she'll just litter the whole
house with them good for her so this is
exciting
yeah do you have a name or now uh yeah
but we just want to announce it okay I
don't care but is it a Mexican name
no okay it'd be cool if it was I was
kind of getting a little excited Shaab I
thought it was gonna be something cool
like that like what do you think
yeah like thanking like Miguel what was
that Mexican Disney movie Coco Coco you
like something like that like Coco Shaab
oh that's fun let you be his nickname
though just come a little coke you know
what are you what is your nationality
what do you think shall sounds Jewish
but only because it sounds like an
investment bank Charles Schwab child no
yeah Charles Schwab Charles Schwab is
different and that's like waspy I guess
she'll I don't shop sounds job is German
German it's to chairman she's also
Hitler's right man for a long time was a
shop really be any relation I don't
think so okay I have to check the 21 and
me you haven't blood I'm not not you
probably shouldn't probably not sushi at
all German German Italian and the my mom
was born raised in England so oh wow
sure all over the place all over man and
you just have one brother yep just this
one here are you still tight with both
parents yeah yeah I mean they're they
live in Denver so as tight as you can be
living somewhere else all right but they
come out see the kiddos everything like
that yeah folks there is no bigger sign
of a loser than a wallet that is I mean
the guy we did kill Tony the other night
and a guy got out and he literally had
just a manila envelope as a wallet I
mean my boomer father used to have a
huge wallet stuffed with $1 bills and
you know business cards of people that
he couldn't sell things with just
falling out of his wallet this is a real
sign of a Boomer is to have a huge
wallet with contacts of all these people
that they don't need and that have never
helped them and you know a huge wad of
cash and a bunch of maxed out credit
cards and debit cards I mean that's the
problem with wallets
really show who you are immediately and
nobody right now I mean they used to say
that the mark of achievement or success
was to take out a fat wallet there's
nothing that could be further from the
truth right now if you have a lot of
cash on you right now you're probably
poor or you're in the Mafia that's
really the two options
you're either criminal you're running a
human trafficking ring and probably they
don't even have cash they've even
evolved okay your congressmen and
Senators in a venn mowing for [ __ ]
kids you know this is not 1997 so you
got to get rid of these big wallets you
know you pull out a wallet at a bar
you're paying for a drink whoever you're
trying to [ __ ] is gonna notice what kind
of person you are you know you pull out
some busted broken-down leather was
probably not even leather too like
leather at or some shitty flea market
wallet you have you take it out of your
pocket people get a notice that guy's a
[ __ ] loser that guy hasn't made any
good decisions that guy's gonna ruin my
life as well as his own that's why you
need the ridge wall and I don't know if
you people have come in contact with
Ridge wallet but it's I've used I use it
everyone on the show uses it Ben uses it
it changes our life many comedians have
it you know we have a credit card or two
in there we have a business card maybe a
business card of your attorney you know
just in case something goes awry and you
know that's it a little cash you do not
need the world in your wallet you keep
it in your phone now everything's been
digitized here's the reality folks the
ridge wallet is a small front pocket
wallet it's it's metal it's great it's
like indestructible you're not going to
lose anything everything is kept tightly
in the ridge wallet okay
it is sleek two metal plates bound
together by a durable elastic band the
ridge looks nothing like a traditional
wallet it's a great conversation starter
titanium carbon fiber aluminum options
ensures there are options for everybody
okay it's a minimal sleek sexy wallet
design the streamline what you carry
every day
it's got 30,000 five-star reviews and
it's a better way to carry your cash and
try this wallet out they will they
literally you know it's one of those
things where if you do not like it they
will give you your money back that is
how confident they are that you're gonna
like it if you go to Ridge comm slash
Tim 10% off your order TI m ridge comm
slash t IM 10% off your order again this
is the future you have a slim small
wallet it's not protruding from your
pants it's not some type of gag that you
take out and start shuffling around to
find what you need
then again I've seen so many losers do
this with their wallets older people
people that you know life just [ __ ]
hit him in the face constantly they
don't know where the [ __ ] they are what
they're doing and they just take out
this big bulbous wallet and they plank
it down on a table or a bar and you see
them and you go what what a waste of a
life and then you know you see all the
information in that wallet their
business cards and everything you go
this [ __ ] has never done
anything I mean that's the type of
person you get a business card from a
furniture salesman and it goes in your
wallet and then you just have 300 years
worth of worthless contacts in your
[ __ ] wallet grow up nobody wants you
doesn't matter you're not doing any
deals with the guy at the furniture
store take his card and throw it out
okay [ __ ] him he's just trying to [ __ ]
you over on that ottoman you don't need
to keep his card there my dad would do
that he'd have cards from people that he
was just trying to rip him off my dumb
boomer dad was I go you've tried to rip
me off I'll save your card you didn't
get me today but hopefully you'll get me
in a week or a month I know you need
this sale you know you just want to hit
him over the head
my dad was like let me let me keep a
wallet of rotating scams let me keep a
bunch of cards just so if I have a
little money one day and I feel like
getting it out of my pocket immediately
I could
all one of these goons and they can take
it from me they can alleviate me of my
paycheck don't be that guy get the
[ __ ] Ridge wallet
okay Ridge calm / Tim T I am I use this
I really do like it again great way to
support the show if you're thinking to
yourself hey I want a new wallet I'm
sick of being a loser and keeping all
this worthless information I want a
small compact front facing sleek sexy
futuristic wallet and I also enjoy the
Tim Dylan show well what a great idea to
go to Ridge comm / Tim T I am okay
alright boomer go and get that wallet
goodbye do you feel do you feel like
you'll ever stand ups changing so much
it's it's do you ever get worried that
we're all in a bubble and that that it's
all gonna come crashing down and we're
all gonna have to get you never will
always be the ones where like like
there's nothing you can do if you want a
network show or something like that that
yeah that you should be worried about
that if you're in TV should be worried
do you ever think to yourself what else
you could do you're like a personality
you could do a lot of different things
do you ever uh no I don't need to
because we're out of the podcast that I
own and then stand up it's like can't
really take these you crazy merch stuff
- we do merge you're getting Florida
like the business would you ever get
into the fashion industry or something
like the access down I could see you
having like seven clothing companies I'd
be down for that yeah you're a smart guy
you're always thinking about like what's
what can I do yeah to make and there's a
lot of like it's like what can I do but
that I'm into that you're into this fun
and that you can yeah do you ever look
around a comics and you go man that's a
talented person but they just [ __ ]
know all the time yeah yeah and here's
the thing and I had this conversation
with a mutual friend of mine who's a
comic and I went I don't why is he not
he should be [ __ ] Jerry Seinfeld and
they were just it see he's just on this
loop like it's never it's never gonna
work he's been doing the same thing like
this is just ya know hope I'm like no I
can help him like a ton you can't help
this guy what do you think it is
self-sabotage bit of just like not a
risk-taker doesn't want put in the work
worried about losing you know maybe an
hour doesn't want you to special do you
think that have you been because I think
New York sometimes for whatever reason
gain can people get in their heads about
purity being a purist and there's only
one way to do it and I'm gonna do it
that way and sometimes not all of them
there's a lot of this amazing people in
New York but like what I like about LA
is that there's there's not really a
line between a guy like me or a Logan
Paul or somebody you know what I mean
you don't think so like in LA I feel
like you know I a lot what do you mean
by line like there's a lot of action
that did I don't and then I don't but
the reality is like he's a guy with an
audience I I don't feel I feel great
going on his show I feel great going on
a youtubers show or social media like in
New York there's such this the line
would be drawn when there's a live
performer when it takes yeah it's time
to be sure end up the line sure he's not
a stand-up that's where York a lot of
people are just not enlarging their
audiences because they're it's like a
circle jerk it's almost an old-school
mentality old-school mentality and I'm
like no you got to get out there and
collaborate with people that are not
stand-up comedy also in tell me if I'm
wrong and I think it's open up more I
mean the Andrew Schultz we're talking
about this yeah Schultz is you know led
the way yeah we're in New York you guys
are very like oh like what you're bone
and you guys be very [ __ ] fight me
for it yeah LA it's like especially in
the group I run it it's more of what
like you're helping each other there's a
lot more money in LA so when there's a
lot more money there's not scarcity in
New York so people are fighting with
each other more I'm a little but that
doesn't make sense more money and what
in what way because he's as you're way
ahead with podcasting you guys made a
lot more money your shows are a lot
bigger there's what was that yeah
but that's not because we're in LA no
it's because you could do it every I
would argue that some of that was the
the nest the necessity of innovation
being in LA not having as many spots
New York City being show focused on
stand-up there was a lot of spots people
just working and being show
busy I think la there's more down time
and people said well what else can we do
how else you know rogen you know
starting that whole thing you know being
you know not being at the Comedy Store
as much because the home and see a thing
yeah I think like that innovation you
guys are just way ahead and there's just
a lot more money and also LA is
Hollywood and movies and TV and there's
a million other things and New York is
not as many of those things so New York
you have status and everybody's kind of
like who's high on the totem pole of
who's a real comic and who does you know
who was working a cellar every night and
who's doing this and who's doing that
there's nothing wrong with that but what
I think starts to happen to people is
they lose sight that there's a larger
world out there and they got to reach
people yeah and but and I think it shows
to not that you know the argument New
York comics brand la comics but some of
the New York comments who will come over
like you mark Normand yeah Schultz it's
like yeah Jesus Christ yeah yeah yeah
monsters yeah I didn't know which way
that was going like Jesus Christ these
guys he's a rough egg or this is a rough
hair terrible to be loud all you guys
are what we like in fantastic a lot yeah
because you guys are doing so much
comedy yeah and it's just like holy [ __ ]
yeah well I think that's be I appreciate
that but I also think man that there's a
lot of beasts in LA - it's like oh
there's a lot of peace there's just a
lot of these there's people that just do
it differently
you know there's people that at your age
now do you see do you look at are you
glad that you waited to get into comedy
cuz are you like I don't think I'd have
a perspective yeah if I was started
younger granted I wish I had the stage
time when I was younger but it's like I
don't want perspective I'd have right
like now I've gone through some [ __ ] ups
and downs and like it gives me more
perspective on life you have a life
where you feel like there's a lot of
drama there's no drop like we are you
somebody who's caught like how does my
drama comes from outside of that I don't
have drama inside my house right kid my
girl there's no drama my drama comes
from my business partners okay who are
other comment right okay I said and then
there and what is it just as coming to
world crazy in our own way
you don't want to do it their way yes
yeah and you would calendar super-tight
but you guys like every now and then
yeah I guess yeah it's very mean town
don't don't bump heads okay
no do you and Theo bond pads ever uh not
really bump heads not really bump heads
no mean Theo we were just worried you
talking about two different kind of
personalities where I grew up on team
sports and Theo and I grow like to me
it's not about a team aspect and feels
learning that right if that makes sense
he's more like me a championship swimmer
because there's nobody on the starting
block except it's all on you understand
it's all on me like you are on you
you're in a football team hiding with a
bunch of other people there whereas I'm
on the block get pressure yep my
family's good name everything right
there on your shoulders did you have a
show yeah did you ever did you ever swim
where you ever swimmer I mean I I mean I
swam as a kid but not compared because I
was good obviously you any type of
athlete no no nothing
interesting that thing did you work out
ever yeah he's starting to work out now
cuz they you know it makes them feel
better right what is the workout what is
the move is it weights car is or what
what is everything man yeah everything
have to do all you have to do it all I
mean you don't have to no but you should
I mean but is it swimming good let's say
I just started swimming [ __ ] yeah do it
what if I just started swimming my
grandma she turns 96 she swam every day
to shoes 19 see that's the move that's
the move she's 300 pounds really but
that's also the move I think those
things are both the move see the gaff
get about miles
he's like everyone's what makes the best
to exercise kefka's like what about
whales he's like do you think whales
[Laughter]
whatever a working [ __ ] king size
Snickers bars at night really good yeah
Colorado just living [ __ ] yes he's out
there live
donar birthday party this weekend that's
awesome but that's the thing I mean
listen you don't want to be big but this
is what happens sometimes it's very hard
the problem is is like you very
different what we do you don't need to
be in some phenomenal shape really don't
worry we don't need to be Joe Rogan no
no no he's insane that he's in any human
level of discipline that we all aspire
to and respect but it's very hard to
then like apply that to your life you
sometimes I don't want to workout for
two hours a day and yeah and that's be
like just never eat sugar and I'm like
right thank you
he's making good right no more sugar
he's like just no sugar no carbs ever
for the rest of you and I'm like okay
you know Tommy's the result so you're
not feeling good so no more sugar no
mile Cano it okay he's like so we're
you're good on that like we're good man
yeah I mean he's it's just gauge in
insane level of discipline I mean you
know why is the country as fat as the
country I mean the country is it's a
public health crisis where everybody's
everybody's like four or five hundred
pounds I mean not everybody but you go
to middle America these are the big boys
you go to Disneyland
what happened it's bad what is it and
you're a guy from that world a little
bit what how do you fix it what world
for the world of somebody who's works
out and is you know just people are lazy
so it's like if you want food it's like
fast food to everywhere so the
government kind of [ __ ] us and just
society fluxes because if you want food
it's like the easiest thing to do is
stop at Burger King somebody like the
healthy options are more expense if
they're harder to get so it's like
already tough to eat healthy then
there's no healthy option what do you
think about this whole thing about fat
shaming and that we're now celebrating
fat people like I don't celebrate fat
people I can't like the models I don't
want my model fat that's not what they
do right that it's a good point it's not
what then what about Liz oh because
Lucille is very very popular lose weight
but lose weight yeah it lose a little it
was a lot like her attitude good for her
like not good liar but I which is
unhealthy but have you seen a new video
where she comes out the diabetic boots I
like that the point is she needs to get
skinny she's gonna explode and her
entrails are gonna hit the faces with
the Bloods on our hands because
everyone's like you go fat girl it's
like I'm the only one going
you don't go fat girl I mean to just
take a shoutin I again maybe I'm not
saying get skinny yeah unless she get
he'll drain it I mean check your blood
pressure but she used to do something
she called out some postmates as opposed
me it was late with her food or
something on Twitter so that's a prop
that makes sense it's a problem if
you're if you call not if you're a
multi-millionaire and you're calling at
a post mate on she's an addict it's in
it's an addiction it's an addictive
listen I've been there
where's your food of choice when the
post page shows up I want to strangle
them oh me too
I go you know what you have other orders
no I get being angry to post me but then
to call Matt on Twitter is like oh
you're [ __ ] not even in your right
mind my food of choice I'd want your go
to I don't know if either go to you like
my praat like what's a problem like for
me a real real like thing that I should
not have it's like if I maybe I find
myself in Larchmont Village oh there's a
salt & straw oh there's a scoop ice
cream these are bad this is it has to be
like really good ice cream for me to go
there yeah I don't eat garbage I mean
either but I have inner Jennie's yeah
it's fine it's nice it's fine salt
straws the numero uno
so it shows better the salted malted
chocolate cookie dough or whatever favor
ice cream and then I get fudge on top I
mean this is and then I walk around
Hancock Park my mouth is watering by the
way but sure like my ice creams always
been a bad thing I actually don't eat
like that like I don't need da man I
don't need garbage food but when I go
out a nice like meatball know I eat all
that I'll be in New York well let let's
say let's say and I'm let's say like you
get done tonight hyenas like like after
we after I'm done with you before
instead of getting stuck in traffic on
the way back to Fort Worth we might go
to a steak house and that's not bad I
can eat good there sure but maybe some
maybe the waiter says something about
like lobster bisque or something I gotta
have it maybe I get a bowl off you're
right
see I gue road like this and while I was
going to four-star restaurant I grew up
eating
you drove rich not rich no not rich my
uncle was in the restaurant business I
might he had a lot of great restaurants
in New York so we were just the only
luxury I ever had as a kid food was food
and that was the only thing that I
learned it like high-end stuff I could
go to really nice restaurants so I've
internalized that palette so my palate
is high alright when I was eight years
old I was eating a parfait of salmon and
tuna tartare with creme fraiche and
caviar
I was like is this a stereo caviar uh uh
you know III you know I'm like is this
Iranian so it's a problem and then I get
into drugs thirteen or fourteen started
with the cocaine third hole thirteen for
woody McCauley comer slide or I know you
were I failed
thirteen fourteen thirteen eighty first
line of code at some New York friends
backyard Long Island and friends
backyard and he got addicted to on the
water of course yeah big to do it no no
I got addicted when I was like 20 when I
was selling subprime mortgages in Long
Island and I was like this is a great
you're unhappy I wasn't thrilled but I
was also like it's a great way to just
be coped up and have a lot of energy and
be on the phone and be talking to people
and be like this world of sales guys it
wore suits and you know drove Range
Rovers wolf on Wall Street I feel you
yeah that's what this is your advice the
wolf but it's not our Wall Street now
nobody had really wolf online but it was
like it was a big issue I mean there was
a lot of issues
well did you hit rock bottom I mean but
it wasn't the rock like everyone's gonna
yell at me when I say what rock bottom
was when we went rock bottom is
different yes I bear says there's always
wiggle room for rock block there's
always a bass you know you're lower but
my rock bottom was I bought a house for
$600,000 that I could not afford but I
just bought this big house and then that
was that started the events in motion
for rock bottom how so just couldn't
afford it and he went bankrupt well I
was just no I mean I was just like
drinking every night at a bar up the
block from my house I was doing drugs
the more it was 2009 the mortgage
industry had collapsed this industry I
thought I was gonna be in forever had
literally just evaporated I was [ __ ] I
wasn't making any money I owed a lot of
money because I bought this crazy big
house it was 23 years old here by
yourself by myself 23 years old hanging
out at a bar up a block from my house
and I could have flushed my whole life
down the toilet then and then I started
doing stand-up comedy in 2010 so thank
God that happened thank God that
happened so I [ __ ] turned everything
around also thank God yeah it's a good
thing turned everything around yeah well
cuz he gave me an outlet for that
passion and then I stopped drinking and
using drugs and then I said well this
energy of being an addict it's got to go
somewhere and then I went instead of 25
I wanted
stand-up love it was about nine years
ago so that so that's what led me into
it and then the the food addiction just
stayed with it the food addiction stayed
with I mean the food addiction is is is
I think it's it's it's it's it's uh
related to the drugs I also think that
it comes from when I was a little kid
like the idea of like oh you eat nice
things you feel good makes you feel good
it's a reward it's how you reward
yourself so all of that stuff I have a
problem with it I mean I have a problem
that's not - I don't know where it comes
from I don't know where yeah sure yeah I
talk to someone about well I'm sure it
just comes from yeah I mean we all have
compulsions like if you weren't a guy
that like you what you do like people
like you have enough money you could
just stop tomorrow but you want to keep
going and doing and getting better and
doing things correct that's a certain
type of person yeah that's a certain
type of person that's somebody who wants
to you know pushed it to the limit but
it's also like I can't like who el Rizzo
was on regulating he goes I once a day
I'm like [ __ ] yeah we're like
Henry Rollins is like Ali drink I wake
him more I drink carrot juice 1 cup of
carrot juice that's all I drink it but
didn't know my house so many many years
of not doing that no you sober forever
forever really never had a touch alcohol
or drug interesting he's just crazy okay
he's crazy people thinks the drugs just
people think I'm still doing try I mean
collegio on a show we'll say Tim Dylan
you know he does he's crazy sketches
he's a sober guy who seems like a drunk
guy that's I mean I put on a wig I yell
and scream as Megan McCain this is not
something a sober person does or they do
yeah or they put its life on and crazy
it's like D'Elia everyone thinks he's
like drugged out all the time never
touch anything
yeah it's interesting yeah yeah yeah
what about sex addiction do you have
that I don't know yeah cuz I know people
with that that and that ruins lives just
like drug addiction we could I'm up but
I'm I have friends it cannot stay
faithful I don't know my thing is is
like I know guys who have that issue
yeah and it's so consuming so
such a deal unravel it unravels
everything trying to do but I want to
get so successful as a stand-up comic
that that's more important to me than
any so you yes need the transference of
all these things into comedy where it's
like let calm how he's keeping me on a
path yeah comedy keeps it I think comedy
keeps a lot of us on a path correct
we're you know whether they're comics or
athletes before if things aren't going
good for them and they get off the
beaten path you don't have anywhere to
put your energy that's where guys get in
trouble right well blue shoe baby blue
Choo you know what it is that's not a
candy it's getting your dick hard blue -
do you have a problem you have anxiety
can you not get it up are you not
sleeping with an attractive partner what
are the chances of that my audience
probably high but you know you still
need to perform not may be great but
adequately you still need to get the job
done so what do you do you need a
chewable dick pill with the same
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis easy
blue - is super easy no awkward doctor
visits you don't have to wait at the
pharmacy and bump into people from high
school ask what you're doing you have to
explain to them that you don't have any
children you move to LA to be a
screenwriter that failed now you're back
working for your folks and picking up
tic pills at CVS none of that
they ship it to your door in discreet
packaging so your mother doesn't know
what you're doing
easy you just go on online free
consultation you tell the doctor what
the issues are and is it a doctor sure
it is why because this email I have says
it is it's a doctor online and they want
the best for you they took a Hippocratic
oath didn't they and basically what blue
Chu will allow you to do is it'll allow
your penis to work blue to calm blue
like the color blue it's the first
chewable dick pill they work up twice as
fast as Viagra and Cialis it's not for
guys you can't perform it's for any guy
who wants extra function to enhance
their performance in the bedroom it's
not just for people that can't get it
out it's for people that want to get it
up over and over and over again maybe
they're addicted to sex maybe they're a
nymphomaniac it's where they derive all
their their their pleasure from their
their their only sense of self is if
they're [ __ ] people that's what this
is for it's not only people that can't
perform it's for people that all they
want to do is perform there's nothing
else
most guys talk a good game I don't agree
with that by the way this hand copy I
think is wrong I think guys a lot of
them don't talk a good game little
especially the guys I know can't can't
say anything you know started taking
their phones out showing people the
photos of building seven but blue two
helps you follow through for round two
blue truths prescribed online ship
straight to your door it's made in the
USA and since blue troop repairs and
ships direct they're cheaper than a
pharmacy it's a good dick pill folks
what are we doing here with selling dick
pills either need them or you don't
maybe you don't need them maybe you
wanna but either way it's a good
situation viagra cialis a big deal you
got to get a prescription it's a whole
thing you don't need that here right now
we've got a special deal for our
listeners visit blue to calm PLU e CH e
W comma get your first order free when
using our special promo code Tim T I am
just pay five dollars shipping folks the
first [ __ ] order is free you just pay
five dollars shipping that's all you
need to do right in time for
Thanksgiving you get a handful of dick
pills for free share them with your
family okay maybe you're gonna meet
somebody Thanksgiving Eve you're gonna
[ __ ] maybe said old that old girl from
high school that used to know and yes
she's 400 pounds now but it doesn't
[ __ ] matter you're also a loser you
need pills to even [ __ ] function so
you see each other out at the bar and
you're really drunk and you're gargling
down food at 3 a.m. you're eating pizza
and you joke around about your old earth
science teacher and finally you go back
to your parents house and bone you know
and yeah you got the blue juice you show
her a really good time and she calls you
the next day and she's like oh my god
that was amazing and you start seeing
each other on and off and then finally
you both moved back to the same town
should get married because you both have
nothing else going on and your parents
pay for a little shitty wedding and you
do it at a VFW and you say that it's fun
and quirky but it really is it's sad and
you marry this girl and you have
loveless sex until one day you you get
it you have a child and the child might
be autistic you don't know it doesn't
really blink and it's kind of creepy and
you say to yourself I hope I'm not
raising a school shooter but at the end
of the day you do what you do and then
you just you know you just you limp
along and life's horrific but it's kind
of okay and listen and then you get
older and the kid gets older and you you
go to Disney World with it you walk
around 110 degree weather with this
[ __ ] fat animal you're married and
you're weird non blinking son who's
definitely gonna shoot up a school as
soon as his fingers big enough to pull
the trigger and you say to yourself as
you're sitting there at an overpriced
shitty resort for the only two days that
you can [ __ ] afford it you say to
yourself god I wonder what would have
happened had I not had the blue true to
adequately perform for this beast I'm
now married to you see you got a life
now I just gave you a [ __ ] life blue2
dot-com promo code Tim goodbye what
would you say on this path what would
you say - what do you think about all
this [ __ ] were people like we don't want
our kids playing football anymore
because well I mean how do you feel
about this weigh-in
what are we thinking um I listen man I
think with with football it's here's
Brendan Schaub I'm fine on football
controversy what I hear right now
do you watch find the Tim Dylan shop you
might have yeah it's just like last
night miles Garrett took a quarterbacks
helmet off and hit him with it okay I
spend for the season that's too much I
think way too much way too much for a
game yes it's the culture we live in
where everything's like this this you
know cancels Jam you should have hit a
woman keep going if you hit a woman if
you're gonna do it hit your partner and
you put on your next game or the UFC
assignment so the thing is is with
football it's just it's like if that's
what they want to do man let him do it
young and they don't know the
repercussions of what they're doing see
I don't think you should let kids eyford
see the brain three my sons three let's
see not playing tackle football Tilly's
I don't know I don't know man
it's a tough two now as a parent it's
tough so he's not playing tackle
football I start playing tackle I think
when I was six which is too early so
you're you say no tackle football for
these kids until they get a little older
yeah I don't want CP we tackle football
we don't need that so show until what is
appropriate on now I'm at middle school
middle school you think they can
evaluate all of the different
replications no I don't I just think
it's what you sign up for a man you know
and here's the other thing is is is
brain trauma like CT is it a problem yes
the majority of players don't have
anything right share about the worst
case scenario the odds are you're gonna
be fun right are you gonna fucked-up
knees and ankles and necks and rise them
but that's what comes with the territory
transgender children playing football
sure like ice box where you on this
[ __ ] planet let's just make the kids
that we're just talking about now
they're transgender trans a little play
man what no but this is a big deal for
it for this is a huge problem now you
have women identifying these men no you
have man identifying these women and
then they beat up women that when it
comes on when it comes to mixed martial
arts that's weird
that's strict but that's the only part
where it's strange really what about
cycling what about you know old men have
all these advantages and then they take
hormones then they become women and then
they dominate no sports is that fair you
don't care okay
so you're breaking with Rogan and hitch
cliff on this
Brendan Schaub for trans athletes this
is very I liked in July cuz I shall
bestow his vote I don't care you don't
care I don't care like cycling or like
in like have you seen the one just like
diesel chick and she's sprinting but
she's not it she's not a she's that she
didn't you know she was in a she was in
a dude that had hormone replacement
therapy and became a chick right he's a
female clitoris everything breast but
she her testosterones through the
[ __ ] roof
right and they're like well her
testosterone is the same as more than
dudes but that's what she's but she's
put on this earth by with whatever you
believe in the creator and she just has
more testosterone but isn't that a
rarity that's rare
that's right everybody's a freak of
nature with all due respect the door
thing right so transport you're cool
with except for the MMA don't the except
for MMA doesn't affect you don't care
interesting don't care
interesting okay whatever may if it's
wrestling it's a little dicey it's a
little dicey if it's cycling don't care
track don't now most people know this
about you you were you were huge
supporter and you funded Donald Trump's
campaign with what do you think about
Donald Trump Donald Trump as a president
of the United States two-term Trump um I
think that I just think we've just got
to do hot buns which is trying to get
clearance hot buttons I feel the same
way bottom we think he's funny he
probably shouldn't be the present that's
literally the way he's a celebrity who
surprised shouldn't be the president I
think the majority of very fun he's very
funny hilarious
I think majority of Americans are sick
of politicians and ones like that who
try to burn it to it could have been
anybody
we're burning the system here's what's
scary when Kanye West goes I'm running
for president
2024 Larocque like damn me my [ __ ]
could win they could absolutely when I'm
making Logan Paul president we've talked
about it a bunch on the show I'm not
gonna talk about it again
I'm done for that but it will happen I'm
telling you sky his brother being the in
in the house is gonna keep his brother
pay a little bit less like Jake we gotta
win like Jake we gotta tone it down it
down a bit we're gonna be fine Jake will
do agriculture we'll put him Tony with
Logan first um when you hear politicians
going millionaires of the problem rich
people of the problem you're somebody
who has a lot of money yes what do you
feel like when you hear that when you
hear Bernie Sanders or people like that
now they're not necessarily talking
about you they're talking about the
billionaire class I'm at the 0.001
percent right but does it makes a person
and their 9.00 one it would come after
these Forks for years [ __ ] because
because I we're out of this I worked
with it I agree I agree and but they're
also all millionaires some of them are
bernie is bernie broke up with sure but
the people they're just angry at rich
people how do you think maybe they're
misguided because some of them have a
point or some have a point the people
you know families in yet billions of
dollars forever but people are self-made
entrepreneurs you shouldn't touch them
that's [ __ ] up yeah that's the
American dream right right what are you
doing I know immigration more less even
girlfriend he's Mexican born and raised
if she is she illegally do it real
interesting now do you ever threaten her
a little called the authority if she
gets wise every Thursday yeah you can go
listen we got a daddy has a good really
yeah talk back from because of course it
makes man it's not that she hates Trump
she doesn't like here's the thing
American Isaac can she read and ride and
everything kind of okay hila stuff a
little bit right she's in an axe
probably smoking she's cool very
attractive
yeah good mother good mother Mexican
dude yeah of course very nurturing warm
yes
does she make a bundle a what's that
kicked open the mobile something like
that yeah yeah what should she kill it
with the enchiladas kills with
enchiladas then they she ordered the
Mexican made around and it's that
interesting dynamic who hears that right
because she hears the answering dynamic
is X commands ever like yeah I know you
think you're white [ __ ] you're in a
white [ __ ] yeah she's like [ __ ] we
know where you come from la Jara here's
the thing though they though in my house
I'm the only one who doesn't speak
Spanish so in my house I'm like it and I
have a whole bit about it's like I'm a
refugee of my own house there's not one
word of English means well your sons are
my son his his first language Spanish
reals English from dad so you have a
speech impediment so it's like it's
tough it's your wild kid how do you see
he's young yet he's it's tough to tell
tough to Dada energy she a lotta energy
but you don't know which way it's gonna
go you don't know I do I'm gonna be like
Jake Paul where you have to like you're
like you have to get out there's a gold
front and key you know should there's I
think it was an article that said 31% of
kids want to be youtubers make sense
there's so much money now so much money
it's crazy how do you feel about society
when you look at what's happening on
social media
and YouTube and things like that does it
make you feel confident we're society's
going I think it's gonna balance out I
think now we're like just realizing how
addictive social media is how it's like
this bullying thing with young kids and
kids who commit suicide there's like
this cancel culture and this hate
culture on there and it's a it's a good
thing that's also super negative and I
think it's gonna sway back over here and
now you see how Instagram is you can't
see likes anymore scrimmaging followers
out oh you think so well this is what
they did with Facebook they started
playing around with it and then it just
became like a haven for boomers to
scream at each other
Instagram I think you're just starting
to play around like the likes it might
not be the biggest deal but I think if
they keep [ __ ] around with it they
keep changing the algorithm that it's
more about you selling stuff well it's
also like how hot to any of these things
stay forever young kids are on tick-tock
now right I don't like to [ __ ] you take
toxic are you on there no I should be
you know tick tock it's that thing where
people are dancing they're falling down
to do crazy things 15 seconds on you do
s they have all those tick tock Chris
like boomerang yeah that's like boomer
it's like a 15-second like a vine but
longer and and it's all those cringe
compliment garfi our friend racism there
no they can't buy tickets you're right
but I'm just saying when you look at
like at one point dozing me something
they sticks around Twitter's around
right what is it was going away but the
Trump energized it and it became
political I like I like Twitter a lot
because you can put things out people
could share them relatively easily agree
so you put a video up but I do like
Instagram to I don't want it to go away
I'm just saying there's always gonna be
the next thing right yeah I think what
we're gonna learn is social media and
you're given these these kind of these
dark demons of voice where it gives them
credibility to hate on successful people
or hate on talented people and that and
also bully kids so I think it's gonna
even out were like oh [ __ ] this isn't
giving everybody a voice in a given of a
pinion it's not good so Brendan Schaub
here on the Tim Dylan show for taking
away the internet from people oh it
really only losers not but so no losers
so not everyone should be able to
communicate on social media they
shouldn't be able to agree they should
be able to communicate to certain people
you know the
it means access is that says this too if
we've got rid of that fourth what we
don't right now let's I wanna we're
talking about walls build that wall
build that wall on social media build
that wall to the people in their dad's
basements to me yeah well there's a lot
of people I think that here's what's
scary when you find out on social media
I think a lot of people are in basements
a lot of people are in their dad's
basement there's a lot of anger there's
a lot of mental illness 100% but there's
also it's their own mental illness yeah
you know I'm standing and it comes out
and I think researchers find like oh
this isn't good it's not good what do
you tell those people that want to
change your life what should they do
let's say somebody's watching this and
they used to hate you stop watching them
stop watching it's a great but stop
watching this accept given five we need
five minutes of the night yeah for sure
but but what what is somebody who's just
a bitter angry person that hates
everybody maybe they're racist maybe
they hate immigrants maybe they hate
rich people valid points you know here's
the thing sure here's the I don't know
anybody I don't know anybody in my group
who are way more successful me
I don't you out anyone who gets online
in sends hate comments I don't know I
don't know I've never done it I don't
know no one who reads YouTube yeah I
don't associate with anyone so yeah yeah
I probably start there by not doing that
right right stop commenting and doing or
just do a do a do a trial test get some
girl you're interested in right I ever
come over years old what are we doing
you go oh I'm gonna send hateful
comments to this comic of this comic see
if she's such a dick how crazy would it
be if the girls like awesome I mean it
is sick man it is sick what are you are
you or the California until you die
Rogan talks about leaving all the time I
mean the state is currently on fire
there's always fires
I literally I'll always have a home
there I feel like to do stand-up I'm
gonna have to be there yeah so I always
have yes always have a home there but I
don't know maybe I'm older I move out
yeah I got a San Diego price stay in
California
you love California love Cal you're not
even though I hate how many people there
are but what do you think of New York is
a city I dislike New York is it get
anxiety it's just me I'm such a hustle
right everything's moving and right the
buildings in RAL the last since its
start doing stamp going back there being
able to hang around like get to know
people and like locals will take me
around I [ __ ] love it
II like it love East Coast now love
Philly boss those are priorities for
stand up common DC Boston geese okay hey
girl what's your favorite place to
perform Wilbur and Boston's pretty good
really yeah that's grandma see in New
York's dope so you're selling out people
love you are you going overseas at all
yep I just I think we just announced it
of 50 shades of brown tour we're doing
Europe and yeah all over men what do you
say what do you think the biggest thing
the biggest advantage that you have over
other people when it comes to like your
ability to you know get people in
theaters and get people out like I don't
think I have an advantage I think I have
a fan base base earned advantage but
it's yeah but I'm just saying like I
don't think I have like some secret or
so like yeah I think Bert Kreischer is
way better at marking than I am Gracie's
way better I don't I don't I don't feel
like I have an advantage when it comes
to that stuff I think you know I put in
year you know me and Brian been together
for six years so what did you meet him
like six seven years ago
how were you stabbed Anna you just met
him no met him and then started doing
the fire and the kid then took that on
the road and that's when I start doing
Stan so fight or the kids been around
for six years and then you guys
developed a huge fan base right out the
gate and took that on the road when did
you meet Rogen I met Rogen I mean what
remember Rogen was a UFC commentator of
course so I was fighting you'll see me
and Rogan were boys and then we got
really close when I moved to LA I mean
him and Brian were the ones who like do
Slater's first do stand-up I first did
stand-up would be yeah I mean first time
we did a live finding the kid because we
did at Bray Improv 550 people does my
and Mike and Brian was like oh you're
gonna go out and do ten minutes stand up
here and he was like so every show and
start doing this this can be open my dad
and how is the pride of the first one go
not great right not grab me not you know
that's right but that's the thing people
like oh you didn't have to do the open
mic scene where no one's around I'm like
hold on you mean open mics where it's
full of other comics hating on the
comics who are performing my open mic
was in front of five or fifty people
tons of pressure yeah it's huge yeah now
and then your first special was show
time how many years after that three do
you feel like we should act you say that
was a crazy fast crazy crazy insane
insane thing to special that anything
nuts yeah wild wild would you do another
one tomorrow no yeah no iPod probably
wait probably two years I might do I
might do something but not a not a not a
our special and you look back at the
special how do you feel about it now I
feel everyone hates everything they do I
hate it I hate I said I would do tonight
in it I'm gonna do tonight yeah I'm
proud of it I'm proud of what I
accomplished short amount of time yeah I
mean the phrase if you have the fastest
person get a like a big Network special
and or certain mount of years right
which is a blessing and a curse but you
know I'm proud of it you know for sure
yeah but it's like I hate everything I
do so I don't know you all I do is
special in three years which will be way
better than that one I'm gonna hate that
one who's your like if you pick one guy
right now were you like this person is
somebody you watched you're like [ __ ]
this guy's great bill burr yeah
well there's a few there's burr yeah
there's a Schultz mark Normand [ __ ] man
there's a few of them yeah yeah yeah
burrs amazed they're all amazing
everyone that you mentioned what you
know for him yeah James great yeah yeah
Ramona said a lot we're on usually
together now are great as far as like
joke for joke talent level for you
nummies top three around the store from
your podcasters at you're like these
guys are bananas do you listen other
podcasts are not really my favorite
podcasts I can't listen other like
Podcast like mine like you know like
silly [ __ ] that we Brian but is your
anybody is there any part
- Shepherd armchair interesting yeah
that's my favorite bug to talk about his
is more of like a she has guests on
there's Monica pad man who's like his
like copilot she's really smart they're
like it's just it's just like
informative he's been through so much
[ __ ] in therapy that he put he like I
learned a lot from it are you a therapy
guy is that a single therapy um I don't
my therapies from like you know I should
go but have time alright it's [ __ ] up
who are people you can't beat up or you
can beat up all comics most every comic
what about Whitney Cummings because
she's very brain jeez kind of crafty
she also has like she's more of a mean
spirit because your guy that was a
fighter do you ever go out in LA and
look at somebody and go that's would be
a tough fight that guys I'm not once I
now fly I don't even think about
fighting well no I can't remember but
interesting I think it's because you're
just just secure God because he's a lot
of little guys oh it's not that I'm
secure I'm more of like these guys
they're gonna think my I'm bad at comedy
I'm thinking for comedy and surreal
watch me they're gonna sue you for your
house
well it's it's like I walk in room like
[ __ ] man these guys know if you guys
don't belong there I'm not as smart as
these guys I want to do it for four
years right so whatever difference yeah
I'm not worried about looking these guys
beat me up right right
what about like that like the think like
you know Rogen's famous for his kick
right he has that famous kick that he
does on YouTube or what not famous first
kick like [ __ ] well you know I don't
mean I mean in the fighting world like
Edison Barboza
no of course but like people will show
me they'll be like look at that kick
that's crazy you have like a fighting
move that you're known for I was known
for like my Darce choke
okay now explain what that is cuz that's
interesting to me it's uh so like if a
guy were to like what's it called
Darce choke dar like with their arms
like this yeah yeah interesting yeah so
you would just choke people it was I was
I was very good at it and getting it
from different all different positions
do you ever wrestling guys
ever watch like WWF WWE Grove I did and
I then I turned 10 and I got over it
yeah I think it's a little depressing
how comics still go to Wrestlemania
whatever in their 30 I mean it's a
little much I can't I can't get into it
I mean Tony Hinchcliffe talking about
salt I'm like I'd a bit like loves I'd
might bit a bit on my social Hulk Hogan
toys like dude come on man you don't
need to be doing that right like - its
Hulk Hogan yeah usually made the sex
tape oh yeah so what Tony said no don't
do it well he's just like come on if
you're gonna do that man you know it's
like they just like they like that's
their Joe Montana or that's their you
know Richard Pryor like that yeah
they're huge I just can't get it cuz you
did the real thing and said why we know
it's not choreographed answer but I
dragged him into it and I'm Brock you
owe me [ __ ] $69.99
I watched I'm like this is terrible it's
not good it's so strange it's not good
in closing what are is your anything
that you would say - you know people
that are excited about what you're doing
and if it like are there are there
things where you're like I want to make
these things better like I wanna like
are there are there things you're
excited to do do you have any interest
in doing anything other than podcasting
your stand-up if you had the money is
your version of Brendan Schaub that puts
Alps that put what that stops doing it
no that puts out a movie that puts out a
documentary that puts out I mean I've
been off of you show then yeah but I
mean like yourself making it like do you
ever say to yourself I want to make more
[ __ ] the only thing I would do is it do
like a buddy comedy like series but with
all our friends yeah Brian
yes the Leo Segura yeah Joey Diaz wrote
yeah all the guys I'd be down for that
but yeah outside that no like I get
offered movie stuff all the time
auditions it's just not
stand-ups London I mean if you had a
phone you could kind of do it
uh-uh you can if it was like with me and
Brian or me oh yeah
but if it's just if it's not is I think
maybe that's direction things would go
eventual agree you know will do but I'll
go and with like you know everyone has
kind of we have this built-in audience
from the podcast you can stand up where
if you think of all our crew in LA it's
like it's kind of a network think how
much power is in that yeah so like all
these like Tommy Central spike all these
networks they're gonna want that
audience they're trying to get in the
digital space
yes sorority that's interesting because
I mean we do so much podcasting and
stand-up there's probably other things
that we could do eventually 100% you
know cuz there's so many like I've
always wanted to do a thing about what I
was like in mortgages and then cast like
Coco Diaz or Santino or like these guy
you know like in like that type of thing
and I think in a few years that would
absolutely be possible and you could
fund it yourself yeah 100% I think that
that'll be the next way agree where can
people find you you want to plug
anything promote anything's come out
this will come out Sunday night I'm in
Salt Lake City Sunday Saturday 8:12 a.m.
so Sunday day Salt Lake City Utah next
week wise guys and ran once guys great
great club don't you I think it's called
something's diner roses diners red
iguana bro red iguanas dope but then
there's also a weird diner up in the
hills it's just beautiful that's nice
yeah I'll get the oh I've Kansas City
first week of December and then I'm in
Jersey I think one night December 14th
fighters or gotta DFAC a.com
teeth back teeth fat K T fat K yep calm
very good thanks for coming on man yeah
thanks for making the time I know this
good to see your brother yeah I'll be
I'll come see you guys soon I hope you
guys yeah you came in looking at was
great
alright guys thanks so much